[موسيقى]
لك ا يا المرتقى الجنه ان شاء
الله 11 نفر طلعناهم دينا كفناه حسبنا
الله ونعم
الوكيل على امي امانه
ام دمار لا مثيل له في هذا القرن يحدث
اليوم في حرب اسرائيل على غزه حسب ما تصف
صحيفه واشنطن
بوست
حرب تقترب من نهايه شهرها الثالث وترتفع
معها الارقام المفجعه
21500 شهيد اكثر من 55 الف جريح
و7000 مفقود معظمهم اطفال مليون و700 الف
نازح ومجازر متواصله اكثرها فضعه هذا
الاسبوع كانت يوم الاربعاء الذي شهد مجزره
في يوم
واحد اصبحت هذه المشاهد تتكرر يوميا وتمر
سريعا في الشاشات وكان العالم اعتادها
ووحدهم سكان غزه هم من يعيشون في هذه
الفضائ واقعا وليس خبرا
عابرا
يحن
ير داد معاناه سكان غزه مع طول امد الحرب
ونتيجه البرد الشديد ونفاذ الامدادات
وبحسب منظمه الامم المتحده لطفوله يونيسيف
فان اكثر من 80% من الاطفال في قطاع غزه
يعانون فقرا غذائيا في حين حذرت منظمه
الصحه العالميه من مجاعه مرتقبه في القطاع
وبرز هذا الاسبوع لون جديد من الممارسات
الاسرائيليه الخارجه عن كل الاعراف
الاخلاقيه اذ اتهم المكتب الاعلامي
الحكومي في غزه قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بسرقه اعضاء حيويه من جثامين نحو 80
فلسطينيا قتلهم الجيش الاسرائيلي خلال
اجتياحه البري المتواصل في الميدان
العسكري تحولت الانظار نحو الحدود
الفلسطينيه المصريه بعد ان كشفت وسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه ان دبابات لجيش الاحتلال
بدات عمليه بريه من كرم ابو سالم لمحور
فيلادلفيا وراى محلي عسكريون ان هذا
التحرك يهدف الى فصل قطاع غزه عن صحراء
سيناء ومصر واستبعد في الوقت نفسه تحقيق
هذا الهدف الرعب الذي يخيم على سكان غزه
يعيش اضعافه جنود الاحتلال ولا سما الجرحى
والمعاقون الذين بلغ عددهم
3000 وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه تحدثت عن
ظاهره الكوابيس التي تلازم الجنود
الاسرائيليين في غزه احد الجنود يعاني
ظروفا نفسيه استيقظ ليلا وفتح النار على
الحائط واصاب جنودا كانوا معه في الغرفه
بمنتجع قرب عسقلان بجروح متفاوته وتتوالى
الهزات على لواء جولاني الذي مني بخسائر
تاريخيه وفقد 44 جنديا وضابطا قتلى في حرب
غزه وكشفت القناه الثان الاسرائيليه ان
قائد الكتيبه 51 في ل واء عزل قائد سريه
بسبب تعريضه مجموعه جنود للخطر بحي
الشجاعيه الله اكبر في قلبهم يا اد حلل يا
دواري وعززت قوات الاحتلال محور خانيونس
بخمسه الويه جديده بعد سحب جولاني ويظهر
هذا بحسب محللين مدى تخبط القاده
العسكريين واتساع هوه خلافهم مع وزراء
حكومه نتنياهو ولا سما مع اقتراب انقضاء
المهله الامريكيه المحدده بنهايه العام
دون تحقيق اهم اهداف العمليه البريه اضافه
الى ضغوط يمارسها قاده اليمين المتطرف مثل
وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي اتمار بن
جفير الذي هدد بحل المجلس الوزاري الحربي
بسبب ما عده اخفاق في اداره المعركه على
قطاع غزه وتزداد هذه الضغوط مع الكشف عن
النزيف الاقتصادي اذ توقعت وزاره الماليه
الاسرائيليه ان تبلغ تكلفه الحرب 14 مليار
دولار في عام
2024 وان تؤدي الى زياده عجز ميزانيتها
ثلاثه
اضعاف وفي التطورات الاقليميه ما يزال
البحر الاحمر يغلي على واقع تهديدات
متبادله فبعد ان اعلنت الولايات المتحده
انشاء قوه مشتركه لحمايه الشحنات التجاريه
في باب المندب انسحبت اسبانيا وايط
ايطاليا وفرنسا من القوه فجاه ورفضت كبرى
القوى الاقليميه الانضمام الى هذا الحلف
وكاد يحدث الصدام بعد ان استهدفت بارجه
امريكيه طائره استطلاع تابعه لجماعه انصار
الله الحوثيين في البحر الاحمر لكن
الصاروخ انفجر قرب سفينه جابونيه وبحسب
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه فان طائره مسيره
اطلقت من ايران استهدفت ناقله تحمل مواد
كيميائيه قبال سواحل الهند دبلوماسيا
تحدثت مصادر اسرائيليه عن اقتراح مصري
للتهدئه ينص على افراج متبادل عن الاسرى
مقابل تعليق اطلاق النار مده تتراوح بين
اسبوعين وثلاثه اسابيع وعلى جانب اخر وافق
مجلس الامن على مشروع قرار وصف بالمخ يوسع
دخول المساعدات الانسانيه الى غزه بعد
اخفاقه في تمرير قرار لتعليق فوري
للعمليات العده
بين اسرائيل وحركه حماس بسبب فيتو
امريكي